for my next tour which uh which would be
called stevo's gone too far to her
transition
close you wouldn't you wouldn't cut off
your dick not gonna cut off my dick but
i'm absolutely getting fake tits
yeah
right now i don't want to i don't want
to give away too much
i know but as i told our jackass
director that that will limit me and how
much potential there is for bits to use
with the tits if they're on my back it's
like there's no well you're definitely
going to get [ __ ] on your tits so
wouldn't you rather that on your back
there's no way you're not gonna have one
of your boys come on your tits
that's
not an idea that i had on the list but
uh get a bigger bucket my friend
[Applause]
it's good but now
here's
like
wait can you add to that can you get the
brazilian butt lift as well
you got to go bbl with them i i am not
ruling that out as a possibility but uh
yeah and unfortunately i have until
next year
to to really it's really making this
beautiful yeah yeah
how big are the tits how bad that dude
my last podcast guest was uh the botched
plastic surgeon dr terry dubrow okay he
says i can go d
so you can go see that
what's that he says you can go d you
could probably go c c is smaller than d
i know isn't he the [ __ ] isn't he the
shitty surgeon
no no no no he's had sex with one woman
that's okay
this this dr terry dubrow podcast was
the most [ __ ] fascinating [ __ ] ever
yeah yeah we're talking about like
what's gonna take to break one and he's
like he's like uh
you know you can get the you can get
your implants with extra saline like
like way extra saline so if you do get
punched by like a professional fighter
in the titty it would rupture and you
want that well
come on
we worked out so much creative with this
guy like i was like if we got like if we
got like a capri sun straw
can i pop it in there and [ __ ]
actually take a step
yeah i did speak with him after that
yeah we can we can at the very least die
the saline if not just [ __ ] use capri
sun oh yeah
here's the thing what's so so deeply
important to me yeah is that in taking
this
from sort of the jackass format to
like the live comedy format where where
like it's actually a comedy show and
each bit gets paid off by the video clip
right
now i unlike a jackass movie where
everything just goes in the bag
like
for my comedy show i really needed to
make sense and to be clever yeah the way
the bucket list is motivated by my
relationship with my girl i'm picturing
that the gone too far tour is motivated
i ask you a question
no disrespect at all what size breasts
does your girl have
she went from uh the committee
to uh
legacy
is
[Applause]
is that not like a a legit joke that
like it's
it's like
faced with a man having [ __ ] legit
fake tits yeah the more embarrassing
thing would be the nipple ring
[Applause]
you